علينا الوقوف لوقت طويل في صفوف الانتظار
حتى نستطيع الدخول الى متحف اللوفر
فالاقبال عاد كما كان قبل الجائحه فبحسب
الارقام الاخيره بلغ عدد الزوار سبعه
ملايين وثمائه في عام 2022 اي بزياده 170%
عن العام الذي سبقه
لا يبدو ان لي الازمه الاقتصاديه تاثيرا
مباشرا على نسبه الاقبال في المتاحف
الفرنسيه الكبيره فرغم الصعوبات المعيشيه
التي يعاني منها كثيرون الا ان نسبه
الاقبال عادت وارتفعت بشكل ملحوظ في عام
2022 كما هو الحال في متحف اللوف
منذ ان اغلقوا كل شيء زادت رغبتنا بالسفر
والقيام بالانشطه
جئت الى هنا لرؤيه الموناليزا والمتحف من
الداخل وهنا ايضا في هذا المتحف
اللجسماته الواقع تعود الحياه مجددا حيث
استعاد متحف الشمع الشهير بريقه مع ارتفاع
عدد زواره في الفتره الاخيره وهو المتحف
الذي يحتفل هذا العام بفكره سنويه 140
لافتتاحه
بعد السنوات الصعبه التي مرت على متحف
الشمع اعداد الزوار الان تقريبا تضاعفت
مقارنه بقبل الازمه الصحيه فالسياح عادوا
باعداد كبيره مثلا خلال عطله الاسبوع
استقبلنا 4000 زائر وهذا امر جيد ومفاجاه
جميله بعد كوفيد
وتميز العام الماضي بحضور كبير في المتاحف
للسياح الاوروبيين والامريكيين على حساب
السياح الصينيين الذين كانوا ممنوعين من
السفر بسبب قيود كورونا زينه عاديه
العربيه باريس